Hello, everybody. My
name is Dr. Richard
Morgan, DPR1
coordinator, as you
know, and I will be
presenting a series
of lectures for the
neurologic exam.
This will be the
first of a three-part
neurologic exam
lecture series. This
one is entitled
Neuroexam 1, Mental
Status, Cranial Nerves,
and the Eye Exam.
So what are the
objectives for today?
We're going to learn
how to obtain a health
history in a patient
with a neurologic
complaint. We're going
to assess the mental
status and review all
the cranial nerves,
all 12 of them, as
well as learn how
to perform the cranial
nerve exam as we
will be practicing
them as well in the
DPR1 lab. We will
then review the eye
examination, as well as
correlate a neurologic
diagnosis from the
cranial nerve exam.
Finally, we'll be showing
you how to document
in proper SOAP note
form the physical
findings for cranial
nerve exam. It'll be more
of a comprehensive
exhaustive look at how
we document it,
although not always will
every single patient
be needed to lay it out
this way. It's simply
for completeness
sake and understanding
a comprehensive exam.
Why do we perform a
neurologic exam? Well,
it's really important,
especially depending
on the reason why a
patient will come to
your office. It can give
you a lot of valuable
information, as
you'll learn from
neuroanatomy. This is one
of the ways we can really
correlate clinical
diagnoses and the
anatomical structures
that you're examining.
What it comes down to
is one simple or subtle
or obvious finding
that a deficit can be
not just lead to one
particular cranial
nerve deficit, but can
also lead to a multitude
of other possibilities
in diagnosing
someone with the
multitude of neurologic
pathologies that can
exist. So really, the
neurologic exam is a
vital key component of any
examination and should
be completed in its
entirety, especially
when you're looking for
a specific neurologic
problem or if the
patient presents with
a neurologic deficit.
What are the components
of the screening
of a neurologic
examination? Well,
in its entirety, we
start with mental
status, right?
Level of alertness,
appropriateness of
responses, as well as
orientations of person,
place, and time.
Second, we include the
cranial nerves. This
will include all 12
cranial nerves. Oftentimes,
times the one could
be left out, but
cranial nerve one has
been more included
lately with the advent
of COVID in the past few
years and other diseases
that do have issues
where the abdominal
nerve is a deficit.
Cranial nerves include
testing visual acuity,
pupillary light reflex,
ocular movements,
auditory acuity,
hearing both gross and
specific deficits,
as well as facial
strength testing, and
then finally speech.
Those are the cranial
nerves. Then the third
component of a
neurologic exam includes
motor. Now, motor
strength testing, you
might think, well,
don't we do that in the
MSK or musculoskeletal
labs? Well, in fact,
in this case, it's
really vital to do
motor testing because
each muscle weakness or
deficit, if you will,
can be specifically
linked or correlating
to a cranial nerve
or other neurologic
deficit. For instance,
12 cranial nerve
involves lexistimus dorsi
and the SCM, the
sternocleidomastoid. So
that's a cranial nerve
specifically linked
to a motor strength
testing examination.
So a deficit there
could directly be linked
specifically to a
cranial nerve deficit.
So motor strength
testing is really vital
in determining as a
component. We always
break things down, neuro,
muscular, but really
they're all
interrelated in a lot of
ways. And especially
with motor system, this
is where you will see
that overlapping, if
you will, of neural
and muscular systems.
Strength testing can
include any role of
following, shoulder
abduction, elbow
flexion, extension,
and so on and so forth.
Next, we have gait.
Gait examination is
vital in not just
neurologic testing,
but any kind of
testing where the
specific pattern of
gait can give a lot
of information as
to what's going on
with the patient.
Coordination is
another thing. fine
finger movements,
finger to nose
and finger to chin,
and we'll be going
with that in
subsequent lectures.
And then reflexes
involving deep tendon in
both plantar responses.
We'll review how to
perform them as well.
Again, everything we're
doing here will show
you how they're going
to be performed in
lab itself. And then
finally, the sensory
system. One modality of the
toes can be light touch,
pain, temperature,
or appropriate reception.
And these are all
important in their
different ways can all
lead to different
deficits that can be found
all along the various
neurologic pathways.
There'll be some slides
that I'll be showing
you that do include
pathophysiology. It's
more for record's
sake, and I'll mention
them as we get to
them. We're going to be
focusing more on the
clinical exams in this
particular lecture,
but I think I'll point
out when they are
important and things
that you will need to
know moving forward.
Now, taking a neurologic
health history, And
we know about our
regular history, right?
But if a patient comes
with a specific neurologic
complaint, your HPI
that you know to ask
the OPP QRSCA questions
are vital. However,
if someone comes to
you with one of the
following neurologic
complaints, we want to do
a more detailed history
as it can be related
to possible neurologic
complaints, or at
least involve in the
associated symptoms more
a clinical picture of
potential neurologic
deficits. Such common
symptoms that can be
presenting are headache,
dizziness or vertigo,
weakness that can be
generalized proximal
or distal, overall
body weakness, or
unilateral facial or
arm or leg weakness.
One other way
patients can
present is with
syncope or passing
out or near
syncopal episode.
Also, a history
of seizures or a
recent seizure needs
to be ruled out,
specific neurologic
pathologies.
And then finally,
tremor or involuntary
movements, something
else. Now, this
is not an exhaustive
list, but these
are very common
reasons why people will
present to their
healthcare personnel.
And in these cases,
a comprehensive
neurologic exam is
appropriate. Now,
if someone came to
me with, you know,
knee pain or ankle
pain, a comprehensive
neurologic exam won't
be necessary in that
example, unless the
patient reports a history
of something more in
-depth with neurologic
findings, either in
their own or in their
family history, that you
need to look further.
But from a neurologic
standpoint, if the
patient presents with
these symptoms, it's
really important to do a
comprehensive neurologic
exam to determine
the potential causes.
Now, how do we do a
neurologic exam? As with
everyone, we start
with taking the regular
patient's history,
the HPI. We do our OPP
-QRST, but we do a
focused exam. We do a
focused questions that
might have more of a
neurologic basis,
right? We're trying to
determine if the deficit
they're presenting
with or the symptoms
they're presenting with
have a specific
localization or if it's a
more general response.
And if so, what is
the localization of
the lesion or lesions?
Are the findings
symmetrical?
What is the pathology
or pathophysiology
of the admirable
findings? And ultimately,
what is the preliminary
differential
diagnosis? And I said
this in DPR, and I'll say
it again because it's
important to mention
that a good, detailed
HPI is going to
give you likely 90% to
95% of your diagnosis
or likely diagnosis
every single time.
Asking the right
questions is everything.
Now, confirming that
with your physical
exam is just as
vital, but knowing
the way you want
to approach your
physical exam all
stems from your HPI.
you start with the
mental status exam right
patient walks in you
get their appearance
and behavior listen
to their speech and
language you notice
any eight pages or
broken speeches or
impaired speeches are they
slurring their speech
um what's their
mood what's their affect
how are they presenting
to you what are their
general thoughts
and perceptions
excuse me and then
ultimately what's their
cognitive function all
these things are just
part of their general
appearance and the
mental status exam.
Now, here's an example
of a Glasgow coma scale.
You'll be given
this, and you'll be
seeing a lot of this
when you're on the
ER rotations or
working in the ICU
settings on your third
-year prefrontals.
But what's important
to note is that Glasgow
coma is the
determination of level of
consciousness in a
patient. Level of
consciousness is based
on three components,
ocular, motor response,
and verbal response.
Each one has a top
score of five, meaning
that a 15 is a perfect
score, meaning the
patient's conscious
and in no distress.
A three is the lowest
score, which means
the patient's unconscious,
and the degree
of between three and
15 makes it usually
a determining
factor as to whether
this patient's in
a coma versus being
completely conscious.
And you'll learn how to
take these scores
when you do them in
the ER and your ICU
settings and whatnot.
Now, I'm not going to
go over every single
one, but I'm going
to give you a summary
of the cranial
nerves that we'll be
going over, cranial
nerves 1 through 12.
Obviously, in order, we
start with olfactory.
As I mentioned before,
it's oftentimes
not always done, but
it can be done in
cases where, like
I said, COVID was a
possible differential or
Kalman syndrome, which
is another disorder
where smell is
lacking and so on and
so forth. And you can
see everything listed
here lists the cranial
nerve with their
function, and then what
the abnormal clinical
finding might be.
Here's the rest of
the cranial nerves, 8
through 12, same
thing. We list them,
and you'll notice some
cranial nerves have
a sensory component,
some have a motor,
and some have both.
In each case, we'll
go over the specific
way that we clinically
do our physical
examinations from a
sensory and motor
component, if need be.
Let's start with
the olfactory
nerve, which,
as I said, this
is testing for
sense of smell.
Simply a way to do
it is you ask the
patient to close their
eyes and you include
one nostril. You
take your test
substance, which is
brought close to the
unobstructed nostril,
have the patient
sniff and try to
identify the substance.
In lab, we usually use a
coffee bean or
coffee grounds.
Oftentimes, some
doctors will use
a coffee smelling
substance like
ethanol, you know,
ethyl alcohol.
cloves, or even
vanilla beans,
depending on the
level of smell
deficit that may
or may not exist.
The examination of
the eye. This is our
visual acuity, cranial
nerve two. This
is broken down
into a couple of
components. We start
with our visual acuity.
We move on to
visual field by
confrontation. These
are both optic nerves.
Then the cranial nerve
three, the oculomotor,
involves pupillary
reaction and response.
Next, we go into the
muscle movements,
which is three,
four, and six,
oculomotor, trochlear,
and abducens. And
then we move on to
anterior and posterior
segments of the
fundoscopic exam.
Let's start with visual
acuity. Here's some
terminology that you'll
be familiar with.
Oftentimes, when
a neurologist or
ophthalmologist comes
to examine one of your
patients on a consult,
these are the terms you'll
often see. VA refers
to visual acuity.
OD is right eye, OS
is left eye, and OU
is both eyes. Latin
phrases are there.
That's just where
you know the meanings
as far as where these
terms came from.
Here's examples of
some of the eye charts
you'll often be seeing
used in offices,
both family practice,
both ophthalmology,
or just in general. In
lab, you will likely
be using the Rosenbaum
or the Snellen chart.
We don't use the
Tumbling E or the
kindergarten chart,
obviously, but some of your
kits, when you purchase
your ophthalmoscope
and otoscopes, they do
come with the Snellen
chart or Rosenbaum
chart, but if you
don't, some of them
will be provided. Each
group will have some
charts provided so you
can practice the proper
way to demonstrate
having a patient read
the eye chart in lab.
Distance visual
acuity testing.
Here's just some of
the nomenclature.
Distance between the
patient and the eye
chart. The distance
in which the letter
can be read by a person
with normal visual
acuity. These are
things you should know.
And know that normal
is 20-20 vision and
anything below normal
is 20-40 or higher.
Some common
refractive errors
that we often ear or see.
Hyperopia, which
is farsightedness.
Really, these terms,
refractive, refer to
the shape of the
ocular globe. So if the
globe is too narrow
or short, that would
cause a person to
become farsighted,
where they can see far
clearly, but things
up close are much
more blurry for them.
Myopia is nearsightedness,
where the globe
is too long. The
light refocus is in
front of the retina,
and distant objects
require a diverging
lens. Okay, this is
probably of the more
common nearsightedness
where people can
often see things close
but struggle with
things in the distance.
Stigmatism, its
corneal surface,
is not perfectly
spherical.
Refractive power
is different at
different axes,
and these require
cylindrical
correct lenses.
And then finally,
transbiopia, which is
kind of age-related
farsightedness, where
the lens becomes
unable to increase the
refractive power to
accommodate on near
objects. So you'll
be hearing and seeing
these terms over and
over, and they come up
a lot in other position
-referral notes.
Just for your reference,
here's an example
of just a diagram of
the visual field of
what you're looking
at. The entire area is
seen by an eye when
it looks at a central
point. The field does
extend farthest on the
temporal side, and we'll
be showing you more
pictures of what the
fundoscopy exam looks
at with some real
-life pictures as well.
Here's just an example
of how the fields
converge from
inocular to binocular
vision. Again, this
is more for your
reference and we'll
be able to apply this
clinically as we do
our physical exam.
Again, this is an
example of what the
pathologies look like if
there's a deficit in one
area and then what the
correlating clinical
finding would be.
Again, we'll be focusing
more on normals in
lab. This is a great,
great slide though
for references when it
comes to comp and board
studying it's a very
common question often
seen on comp exams comlex
and the usmoes they
love this type of
exam where you find the
deficit or it's presented
in a clinical finding
and you have to
determine what the
deficit is where they'll
give you the clinical
presentation so it
really is important to
know this slide moving
forward we're going to
focus more on normals
in this particular
lecture next we have
visual fields by
confrontation for the second
cranial nerve, all
right? What's this part
called? This is the
static finger wiggle test.
And you might have
had this done before.
The way we do it, as you
can see in the picture,
you stand up just
in front of the
patient, have them
look directly into your
eyes. Then the
physician takes their
hands two feet
apart, lateral to the
patient's ear, so
they're out of sight.
They have to
be looking at
you so they
can't see them.
You start to
wiggle both fingers
and simultaneously
bring them
slowly forward
as if in a bowl.
perving inwards
towards central vision.
You let the patient
know as they're looking
directly into your
eyes as soon as they
see movement. And
commonly without deficits,
patients can see them
very quickly. But
it's important not
just to do this in one
frame of reference, but
in all four quadrants
so that the patients,
you don't want
to miss any kind of
visual field deficits,
especially if a
lot of times you
might be missing in
one or more areas.
And if you only
check one, it's not
as comprehensive
as it should be.
Further testing for
visual fields by
confrontation also include
finding if a defect is
found with the static
figure wiggle test,
then you test each eye
at a time by having
the patient covering
their eye with their
hand and the examiner
covers their opposite
eye and you repeat the
wiggle test by having
them while they're
having the patient keep
the gaze with you and
at a point that they're
staring at equal
distance between the
examiner a patient,
you move the wiggling
fingers into the defect
area until the patient
reports seeing it. And
of course, you want
to do, as we always
do, do everything
bilaterally and repeat
the steps in different
levels so you can map
out the defect. It might
only have trouble with
the lower field on
one side or the upper
field on the opposite
side. So it's important
to really document
where that defect is
noted on your exam.
Now, inspection. With
everything we do in
our physical exam,
always remember to
include inspection,
and that includes the
eyes. Standing in
front of the patient at
eye level, assessing
asymmetry and position
of the eye, as well
as proper alignment.
Check the eyebrows out.
Look for symmetry or
sparing a pair. Is
there drooping on one
side? Inspect the eyelids
for ptosis or swelling
or lesions, or even
eversion inversion of
the eyelids. Really
pay close attention.
Remember, inspection
is vital. People often
overlook it, but it truly
gives you a baseline
for what you need to
go further into depth.
Here's a couple of
minor basic examples
of what you might see
on inspection. The
first one on the left
there is an example
of conjunctivitis,
where there's a little
bit of discharge
coming, purely discharge
coming from the
conjunctiva. The second
example is exophthalmos,
which is enlarged
eyes or protruding
eyes, which is often
seen in the thyroid
condition called
Graves' disease. This
is an example, a classic
example of what that
would look like.
Then finally, ptosis.
This is a unilateral
ptosis. In this case,
this gentleman has
ptosis or drooping
eyelid on the right.
It's often seen in
myasthenia gravis and
some other neurologic
diseases as well.
Now we want to
make sure we don't
forget to assess
the pupil. Why
is this important?
Pupillary size
tells us a lot,
right? Tells a lot
about what could
be going on
with the patient,
if the pupil's
too big, the
pupil's too small.
And it can often, we
can use that information
that we get to
combine with what we
gathered in our social
history, in the history
of the patient, or
what they told us
about what's going
on with them to help
determine if they're
being truthful or not. And
I'll explain. So pupil
size can be measure
using a card, and
you'll see that it's
often found at the
bottom of the Snell and
the Rosenbaum charts.
You can often easily
measure by putting it
up to the patient's
eye. Generally, if
they're greater than
five millimeters,
it's considered large.
Anything can vary from
one to five, even a
little bit bigger. The
most important thing
is to see symmetry. But
if there's obviously
increase in size,
like greater than five
millimeters, it's
considered large.
Anything less than three
is considered small.
And here's an
example of why this
is important,
right? So here's a
normal one in the
left upper picture.
That's a normal
pupillary response.
Now you can see
one that's meiotic,
where it's a
pinpoint pupil in the
bottom left. Why
is that important?
Because the patient
could be on a substance,
such as an opioid
or painkillers or
anything like that. And
if they were not truthful,
let's say, in their
social history,
where you took a
detailed history, and you
might be able to
combine other neurologic
findings in your exam
that tell you otherwise
from what the
patient might not be
telling you in honesty.
So it's important
to get this
information. The
examples on the right
show a dilated pupil.
And the same thing
goes for this.
The pupil in this case
is enlarged. And in
the bottom right, it's
extremely enlarged.
And that's usually
due to more of a
stimulant-based medications
that the patient's
on or drugs, such
as methamphetamines,
*******, Ritalin, and
other diet drugs. So
it's important to note
pupillary response
and correlate that with
possibly the social
history with what's
going on the patient.
Pupillary response
includes the oculomotor
nerve. In this
case, simply what
we do is we direct
the pen light into
the eye while the
patient's looking at
a distance far up
over your shoulder.
You confirm
that the pupil
constricts to light
and you compare
pupillary diameters
bilaterally.
Not necessarily,
we always just
measuring them, but
we're looking for
a symmetrical
response response to
constriction that's
somewhat equal.
Then we do a direct
response and a
consensual response.
Every time you do a
pupillary response,
it's both direct
and consensual.
What's the difference?
Direct response involves
looking in the eye
that you're actually
shining the light
in. In other words, the
ipsilateral eye. You
put the pen light into
the eye, you notice
the constriction. The
consensual response
should also be done.
And what that does is
when you're shining a
light in the ipsilateral
side, you're looking
for contralateral
restriction. So in this
case, the gentleman
has the eye, the
light shining in his
left eye, and at this
point, you're looking
for a consensual
response, which is
constriction of his right
eye, all right? And you
can do both separately.
You do both direct
responses first, and
then do both consensual
responses first.
And again, it's very
important. This tells
you a lot of valuable
information that you
could need later on
in your diagnosis and
possible treatment.
Here's a pathophysiology
of the pupillary
response, what it
looks like. Again,
this is going to be
something you can
combine with a lot
of your neuroanatomy
lectures. I won't get
into any great detail,
but it gives you
an idea of how the
eye responds and why
what occurs and why
the eye is constricting
on one side with
both a direct and
consensual response.
next we have the near
reaction or convergence
this is two other
ways that we could
actually measure constriction
of the pupils and
what do we do the near
reaction okay is a
pupillary constriction
with near effort okay
this is what we can
use in lieu of light if
the patient is like
let's say hypersensitive
to light we can use
this as well what we
do is in normal room
light we stand in front
of the patient holding
a pencil or your
finger 10 centimeters
from the patient's eye.
You have the patient
look to an alternate
place way behind you
to be on a far wall or
out the window in the
OMM lab, anything like
that. Once they're
looking out, at that
point, you're staring
at their eyes. And then
while you're looking
at them, you have them
look and start to
converge or you have them
look near at the object
in your hand, which
should be a pencil,
like I said, or your
finger. As they move
from far to near, hence
the near response,
you'll notice that the
pupils will constrict
and that's a normal
response is a bilateral
constriction as their
their gaze goes from
far to near and that's
what you're looking for
in the near reaction
convergence is a
simple way that we can
measure to see that
the eyes are working
together synchronously we
have the patient follow
your finger object
that's approximately
12 inches from their
nose about five to eight
centimeters off of
that and normal would
be as as you move the
pen or pencil closer
then you'll see the eyes
kind of moving merging
or converging
synchronously. And again,
you're looking for
symmetry. If there's one
eye that's not, maybe
you notice nystagmus,
which is a tremor of
one eye. All those
things can be noted and
should be documented.
Here's just an example
of the extraocular
movements. The next
component is, it seems
overwhelming, and I
want to stress this
with the cranial
nerve exam. There's 12
cranial nerves. There's
a lot going on here.
And we're breaking
them down slide by
slide so you can see
how these work. But the
bottom line is, when
you get efficient
with doing this, and
practice makes perfect,
right, really urge
you to practice
these at home and with
your colleagues and
with your family members,
when you continue
to practice this,
you'll be able to do
this whole neuro exam
in literally two to
three minutes, maybe
sooner. It really
goes quick. And here's
an example of why.
Cranor nerves three,
four, and six, okay,
checking for oculomotor,
extraoculum movements,
checks for a number
of muscles within
the eye. but it's simply
doing a one test that
takes no more than
10 to 20 seconds. And
I'll show you what I
mean. How do we test
extraocular movements?
You stand in front of
the patient, you ask
them to follow your
finger with their eyes
only staring right at
you and only moving
their eyes, not their
head. They can't move
their head and you proceed
to make a wide H
pattern in the air
covering all six cardinal
directions of gaze.
If you do that, and it
could be done, like I
said, within 10 to 15,
20 seconds, you can
actually that will
cover all three cranial
nerves and then you
do it bilaterally oh
it's done bilaterally
so that will tell you
um exactly what if
there's a deficit or if
it's everything's normal
so making that wide
h it's best to follow
a pattern when you
stop in each quadrant
okay so making that h
you start on the upper
left let's say you move
your finger straight
down having the patient
remain keeping their
head fixed and only
moving their eyes to
look at your finger.
So left upper to left
middle to left lower,
and then back up to
left middle, and then
over to right middle,
and then right upper,
right middle, and
right lower. So you're
literally making an H
but stopping at each
quadrant, pausing just
a moment so that the
patient can follow
that gaze of all the
patterns. And that's
really as easy as it gets.
Here's just another
example of octal
the motility, and
which muscles are
involved in each
ocular movement.
So again, this is
good for references.
Combine this with your
neuroanatomy lectures
and things you learn
in an anatomy lab,
and these will
definitely help
you understand
ocular movements.
Here's just an example
of a diagnosis of
different ocular
movements. As you can
see, The upper one is
normal, and then you
see that there's
various movements that
will diagnose a certain
pathology based on
the way the eyes are
moving as they're
turning. You can see
the various differences,
and I'll let you
think about this and
come up with the
diagnosis on your own.
Now we'll get into
a little bit of the
fundoscopic exam with
the ophthalmoscope,
this wonderful
device that you
all purchased or got
from your siblings
who went to med
school or parents.
and you brought
it to lab, and
now we're finally
going to use it.
So we're going to have
a whole demonstration
of how to use them
in lab. The scholars
will go over it,
your individual pods
will review how to
use this equipment,
and I'll touch on a
little bit of it here.
How do we do the
fundoscopy exam? Well,
in the OMM lab, I
will shut the lights
off, and the whole
room will be darkened.
It gives you a
much better way to
examine the red
reflex and the fundus.
Lens should be
turned on to the
large, round, white
beam of light, and
it should be set
to zero diopter.
The optomoscope
should be held in your
right hand to
examine the patient's
right eye and left
hand to examine the
left eye. So it's
always right hand,
right eye, left
hand, left eye, okay?
You start by placing
yourselves 15
inches from the
patient and add a 15
degree angle from
their line of vision.
And you ask them to
focus on a distant
object and keep
that gaze fixed.
The point is from
that point of 15
inches away, your
purpose using the
light to shine
into their eyes to
determine and look
for the red reflex.
Now, with the
fundoscopic exam, as you
move and you catch the
gaze of the red reflex,
an example could be
seen in the picture
on the bottom, what
happens is you're
placing, as you move
toward the patient and
you get that red
reflex in sight, inside
the fundoscopic, inside
the ophthalmoscope,
once you come up
close to the patient,
your comfort is just
as important. So what
you want to do is place
your thumb of your
free hand on the
patient's eyebrow with the
ophthalmoscope and against
your bony orbit. And
what that does is
it gives you better
maneuverability and give
better stability and able
to monitor and maneuver
the ophthalmoscope
in your hand without
causing any kind of
accident or injury in
the patient or whatnot.
And when you shine
the light in the
eye, you will see
the orange glow
of the pupil, which
is known as the
red reflex, as you
can see it here.
with the fundoscopic
exam you want to continue
to keep the light
beam on the eye and
continue the 15 degree
angle until you're
almost touching the
patient's eyelashes and
then you locate the
optic disc by following
the blood vessels
and seeing where they
converge and noting
their *********** as
you approach the disc
focusing using the lens
disc to bring the
retina into focus if
the patient is myopic
or nearsighted you want
to adjust the lens
disc counterclockwise
which is the red
numbers and then if the
patient is farsighted or
hyperopic you can adjust
the lens disc
counterclockwise with the
green numbers which
is the diopter power
display as detailed here
and again we'll go over
this in lab we'll
have the scholars
demonstrate it we'll
also work on it
in the individual
pods finally here's
an example the
fundoscopic exam of what
normal looks like on
the left here this is
what you will be seeing
inspecting the optic
disc for clarity color
of disc size, of
central physiologic cup,
really want you to spend
more time understanding
what normals are.
You know, I gave you
an example of an abnormal
such as papilledema,
which is ocular swelling
from an increasing
cranial pressure
or edema, causing
interaction, intraaxonal
edema along the optic
nerve. And that's what
the difference is between
these two. It kind
of looks like it gets
a little fuzzy and
harder to find the optic
disc and then the
blood vessels also get
blurry as well. But
focus on the normal one.
You want to see enough
normals and then when
you see enough normals
you'll start to know
what abnormal is. But
most importantly is
just to recognize the
normal so that when you
see an abnormal you
know something's wrong.
Not everyone's going
into ophthalmology so
it's okay if you're
not sure what you see.
But you want to know
some of the basic
conditions to look
those up and especially
the more common ones
that you'll be seeing.
In the
CPG for this lab.
I'm going to put a
link to a short
YouTube video that will
give you a nice
example of how to do a
fundoscopy exam.
Shutting the lights out,
the whole thing
in one nice fluid
motion. It's about
6-7 minutes, but it
gives some really good
insight. I'm going
to put that on the
CPG for this lab.
Next, we have
the trigeminal
nerve or cranial nerve 5.
Again, this is a
sensory and motor
cranial nerve,
so we're going
to start with the
sensory first.
Using a pin or a
cotton swab, we assess
the three distributions
of the trigeminal
nerve, which
include ophthalmic,
maxillary, and
mandibular. For all you
OMM fans out there,
which are all DOs or
hopefully on our
way to becoming DOs,
I always like to
remember the mnemonic
is OMM. So you'll
never forget the
branches of the
trigeminal nerve because
the mnemonic is
OMM. Nice and easy.
We always test
bilaterally,
of course, as
with anything.
Next is the corneal
reflex. I mentioned this
for completeness
purposes. We will not be
doing this in lab. We
don't want students
sticking their fingers
in their colleagues'
eyes, causing a whole
bunch of corneal
abrasions. So you will
be practicing this and
need to know it for
your clinical rotations
down the line. But
for purposes of this
lab, we will not be
performing it. But
essentially what you're
doing is at a patient's
line of vision, you're
touching the cornea
light, either the fine
whisk of cotton or a
cotton ball or something,
and then you're
expecting for closure
of both eyelids, which
is blinking, which
is a normal response.
So just keep that
in mind. We will not
be doing this in lab,
but for completeness,
you should be
familiar with them.
Next is the trigeminal
motor. This is where
we palpate both the
temporal mass or muscles.
Nice and easy. We do
it bilaterally and
ask the patient to
simply clench their teeth
and note the strength
of the contraction. And
then we have them
move the jaw back and
forth side to side, and
that gives inside us
the trigeminal motor
component real quick. Like
I said, these things
go really quick. These
are not time-consuming.
It seems overwhelming.
But again, once you
get familiar with
practicing these in a
condensed, practiced,
conduced version, you'll
be finishing these
really, really quick.
You know, by the time
you start rotations,
you'll be down to like
hopefully two to three
minutes or even less.
Next, we have
the facial nerve.
Again, sensory and
motor components. In
this case, we're
going to be
demonstrating the
motor component, okay?
So the motor, nice
and easy, it sounds
complicated to
check the facial
nerves, actually
just performing a
series, having the
patient go through
a series of six
different motions.
Asking the patient to
raise their eyebrows,
smile, show their teeth,
close both eyes
tightly without
letting them open
because remember
cranial nerve
seven, you need
cranial nerve seven
opens the eyes,
so three closes
them, but seven opens
them, so we want
to have the patient
try to open their
eyes, and that helps
determine resistance
to eye opening.
And then we have
frown and puff cheeks.
You can have them
do this again. It
takes 15, 20 seconds,
and the facial
motor component is
done. Nice and easy.
Again, we will
be practicing all
of these things
in our neural lab.
Again, here is
another example of
pathophysiology, of when
there is a cranial R7 or
either peripheral or
central lesion. For
completeness sake and
for your references.
Once again, great
board topic. They love
asking questions
like this of where
the clinical finding
is versus where's the
lesion. They want
you to be able to
kind of apply
pathophysiology to clinical
settings so you can
really get a good
grasp of what you're
seeing and how you
can relate it to a
specific diagnosis.
Next, we have acoustic
or vestibulococular.
This is the auditory
component of the exam
or the eighth cranial
nerve, and it's broken
up into a couple of
parts. We'll start with
the sensory. Really gross
auditory acuity just
involves having the
patient cover one ear
and you can whisper a
word or number to them
from two feet away,
have them repeat the
word or number, and you
can pair bilaterally.
Alternatively, I like
this one a little bit
more because it's more
sensitive and patients
oftentimes will always
hear you talking,
but they may not
always hear you rubbing
your fingers. So in
this case, you cover the
ear, they cover their
ear, and you rub your
finger and thumb and
forefinger together
next to the uncovered
ear and ask the patient
as if the sound was
heard. And you compare
them by latterly.
You don't need to do
both, but at least one
of them will suffice.
Now, we go on to the
next component of
hearing testing, and
that involves two
basic tests, the
Weber test or Weber
test and the René
test or René test.
The Weber and René
are like peas and
carrots. Both of them
need to be done if
you're assessing
someone for hearings.
So when are these tests
done? They're done
if someone comes to
your office where they
have either acute or
chronic hearing loss, and
you want to determine
what type of hearing
loss it is and where
it's coming from. So
how do we determine
that? We start by doing
the Weber test. The
Weber test is testing for
lateralization of
sound. So what does that
mean? We take the
tuning fork in your bag
as the one that's shown
above, the 512 hertz.
We vibrate it on our
hand or on the table,
and then we place
it on top of their
head, and then we
ask the patient to
identify where they
feel the vibration.
Oftentimes, for a
normal patient, they'll
feel it just in the
middle of the head,
which is normal,
and it's not called
lateralization. Now,
the patient, let's say,
you put the vibrating
tuning fork at the top
of their head, and now
it's vibrating, and
they feel it down the
left side to the left
ear. That means that
they have left-sided
lateralization. What
does that tell us?
Well, for the Weber test,
if it lateralizes to
the left side, That
means that they either
have conductive hearing
loss on the left or
sensory neural hearing
loss on the right.
So how do we determine
which is which?
Then we take the next
part, which is where
we do the Rene test.
The Rene test will
tell us if it's
conductive on the same
side or neurosensory
on the contralateral
side. So how do we do
this test? We take the
same 512 hertz tuning
fork. we strike it
again to create the
vibration and place
it at the mastoid
process behind the ear
being evaluated. So if
they were lateralizing
to the right ear,
let's say, then you
put this and start
on the right ear. You
put the vibrating tuning
fork on the mastoid
process and ask the
patient to let you
know when they no
longer hear the sound.
Once they no longer
hear the sound, you
move the tuning fork
just next to the
ear and ask them if
they can still hear
the tuning fork. This
helps us determine
the difference
in length of time
between bone and air
conduction, right?
So first we're testing
bone conduction,
but if they still
hear it, that means
air conduction is
lasting longer, okay?
What does that tell us?
Well, here is what
it tells us. So for
normal, the air
conduction is always
greater than bone
conduction, right?
It makes an inducing
sense that air
conduction will
last longer. For
unilateral sensorineural
hearing loss,
air conduction will be
greater than
bone conduction.
But for conductive
hearing loss,
most commonly, the
bone conduction will be
greater than the air
conduction. We're going
to go over this in lab.
I think it's easier
when you see it done. But
I think it's important
from a standpoint
where sometimes it's
hard to combine the two.
So just to reiterate,
the Weber test tells
us which side it
lateralizes. If it
lateralizes to the left side,
that tells us it's
either a left conductive
hearing loss or a right
sensorineural hearing
loss. The Rene test will
tell us specifically
if it's conductive or
sensorineural based
on which is longer
arrow bone conduction.
Here's an example of
doing a couple tests.
So here's where
the first one, it
demonstrates the
Weber test sound
lateralizes to the left
ear, right? So like
I said, that tells
us if it's left
conductive or right
sensory neural.
Then we do the Rene
test. And in this
case, you see the bone
conduction is greater
than air conduction
in the left ear.
Air conduction
is greater than
bone conduction
in the right ear.
Therefore, we have
a conductive hearing
loss, which can
involve cerumen,
earwax, foreign body,
or maybe otitis media,
which is an air
infection in the left
ear. And again, this
is probably the most
common type of hearing
loss there is. Most
people you see might
have cerumen impaction.
They don't clean their
ears properly. They
develop a lot of
wax buildup. And
inadvertently, where they
feel like they've slowly,
subtly lost hearing
over time, it actually
could be due to wax
buildup rather than
any kind of infection
or other foreign body
needs. And it's
thought that there's a
decrease in the
masking effects of the
background noise with
conductive hearing loss.
Second example is
with Renee. If the air
conduction is greater
than bone in the
left ear, and it's
also greater in the
right ear, this is
a conclusion where
sensory neural deficit
is more likely,
or like otosclerosis
or something
along those lines, and
that would be in
the right ear.
Next, we have
cranial nerves 9
and 10, the
glostoparyngeal nerve.
Again, this is
sensory and motor.
This involves a
gag reflex or taste
for the posterior
third of tongue.
As similar to the
corneal reflex, this is
something we will not
be practicing in lab.
We don't do gag
reflexes. We don't need
patients, students,
gagging all over the lab.
But again, it's for
completeness sake,
and you will have to
know it if you're doing
IM or neurology rounds
or even PM&R where
you work on ******
patients, where it is
important to really
determine a gag reflex.
Creator of 10 is the
vagus nerve, again,
both sensory and
motor components.
Again, this is how
you can actually just
listen to the quality
of the patient's
voice. Is it guttural
or frog-like?
Does it have a
normal quality to it?
Then you can have
the patient swallow
and observe
them to see if
there's normal
swallowing components.
Then instruct the
patient to open their
mouth and say, ah,
looking for symmetrical
movement of both
the soft palate
and location and
movement of the uvula.
Again, gag reflex
is important to
know, but we will
be not demonstrating
them or practicing
them in the lab.
Next, we have the
spinal accessory
nerve, cranial nerve
11. This is only a
pure motor nerve.
The spinal accessory
nerve innervates both the
sternocleidomastoid and
the trapezius muscles.
So we want to
basically do motor
strength testing of
those two muscles.
So first thing we
do is we can palpate
what we expect for
atrophy of either
muscle group or
fasciculations bilaterally.
And then we ask
the patient to
simply shrug their
shoulders against
resistance. That'll
be for the trapezius.
Secondly, with the
sternocleidomastoid,
we're checking
for side network
for rotation of
the cervical spine.
for the rotation of
that neck, which then
will determine a
weakness of the
sternocleidomaxone on
either side. And this
is done, as you can
see in the picture,
by placing your hand
on one side of the
patient's face and
asking them to turn
their head towards
that side. You apply
resistance and
notice any deficit or
weakness on one side,
which will then tell
you if there's a
deficit of that nerve.
Finally, we have
cranial nerve 12, which
is the hypoglossal,
which is a pure
motor nerve. This is
basically the tongue.
So in old days, when
I was in that school,
they would have us
put on gloves and
grab the tongue and
move it left, right.
These days, it's
pretty straightforward.
You instruct the patient
over their mouth.
You inspect the
tongue as it lies on
the floor of the mouth.
You have them protrude
their tongue, move
it left to right.
Notice for any asymmetry,
atrophy, deviations
from midline. Then
finally, you instruct
the patient to move
the tongue from
side to side, and then
even have them push
it against the inside
of each cheek, so
that will tell you
your strength of the
tongue, all right? So
it is important to check
all that, and like
I said, it doesn't
take long at all. It
really is important
when you're examining
the gradient layers.
Here's an example
of what a deviated
tongue looks like.
This patient with
acid the signal comes
straight out, and
you can see it
deviates to the left,
so patient's left.
So the diagnosis here
would be a left
-sided deficit of a
hypoglossal nerve.
It's usually, it's
always ipsilateral in
most cases, that it
deviates to the side
that's affected.
Finally, here, we're
going to just go over
documentation of a
normal neurologic exam,
um how we do this it's
all going to be laid
out in a very
comprehensive fashion and i
want to reiterate as
well that in all of
your skill sheets for
all the skills especially
the neuro skills
there's examples of
normal documentation at
the at the end of all
the skill sheets so
please keep that in
mind you have multiple
resources at your
disposal to help determine
the proper way to
write a soap note in
addition to the ones
we'll be doing at lab
so how do we write this
the neurologic exam
would be your mental
status. And of course,
I'm writing it out
here, but you'll be
able to use a ton of
abbreviations. For
instance, A&O times three,
***, normal speech
comprehension, speech
fluid. You'll be able
to shorten a lot of
this down. But for a
comprehensive exam, we
want to lay out the
entire Crane and Herb
exam so you can see
how it's often written.
Crane and Herb 1,
as you see here, is
not tested. In many
cases, you won't be
testing Crane and
Herb 1. Most ERs are
going to have you sit
there walking around
with coffee beans.
And what you'll see
in most notes, it'll
say cranial nerves
2 through 12, mostly
intact, bilateral.
If everything's
negative and normal,
you can actually
just write that. But
for completeness
purposes, we want you
to see how it's
completely written out.
So here you have
cranial nerves 2 and 3.
You can see how it's
all written out here.
Excuse me.
Moving on to cranial
nerves 5 through
12. Same thing here.
Facial sensation.
It goes into very
specific detail.
Now, it's important
to write this out. If,
you know, you're
doing a comprehensive
neuro exam and you
find specific deficits,
one other way to write
it when you're writing
your note will be
cranial nerves 2 through
12, grossly intact,
except for cranial
nerve 5 deficit on
the left or positive
deficit of cranial nerve
12 on the left. You
know, so you could
write out what's normal,
everything's normal,
accept, and then do
it that way when you're
doing your exam. But
for completeness sake,
I want you to see
how each one is
individually written down.
Again, here's a
documentation of the
normal exam. Again,
painting on herbs,
written out, so
you can see how you
would each write it
on each component.
Finally, how do we
document this in a SOAT
note? Again, there's
examples of some of these
things that we'll be
showing more in lab.
And after you've given
the doorway information
here, you have your
general appearance.
Again, appropriate
abbreviations can be used.
Patients awake, alert,
and oriented. They
appear their stated
age and well-groomed.
And you can see
with the HENT,
it includes the
ocular exam.
The visual acuity tests
are done here,
PERLA, EOMI.
Again, using your
abbreviations,
you'll be able to
do that as well.
Ear, nose, throat
are also included
for cleatness
sake. so you can
see the whole
HNT written out.
So how do we prepare?
How would we like
you to prepare for
DPR 1 for NeuroLab,
which will be
soon after this
you read this.
Please be dressed
in appropriate
DPR lab attire.
Please bring your
charge ophthalmoscope
visual acuity card.
If you don't have one,
one will be provided
for your pod. We have a
few extras. They need
to be returned, but
you'll be able to use
something. But a lot
of the kits do come
with Rosenbaum cards.
In addition, please
bring a pen light if
you have or a tuning
fork. If you only
have your phone, you
can use the bright
light on that, but
it's much better if
you do have a pen
light at your disposal.
Finally, review,
review, review.
Please come to
lab prepared.
We won't, the
labs will be chock
full of skills and
we get to as many
as we can, but we
don't always get
to all of them.
But it is your
responsibility to
read the skill sheets,
practice the skills
even before coming
to lab. The more prepared
you are, the more
seamless the transition
will be as we
go through a very dense
two-hour lab period
where we're going
through all these
skills. As you can
see, there's a lot of
them, and we'll be
going over all the
cranial nerves in the
first lab. So please
review your neurologic
skill sheets for
mental status, cranial
nerves, and HDNT.
And just always come
prepared to lab. It
will be so much easier
when it comes to being
able to help you so
that you have at least
some experience and
knowledge coming in.
and hear us listen
the references
everything comes from
bates to john and then
the dr schwartz
edition for physical
diagnosis and that's
about it i want to
thank you for your
time i will see you
again when i do the
second lecture for the
neuroblock um have
a wonderful day and
i will see you in
lab thank you again